-I'm so happy to see you
in studio.
You've been so nice to come on
the show through
Zooms and all that stuff.
-And where was that?
Was that hanging
on a screen here?
-It was a screen
behind you, yeah,
and so that's were you were.
And, weirdly enough, you were in
the building Zooming.
-Oh, yes.
-You just didn't want to come
into the studio to see me.
-No, no.
I mean, I live right here.
-Yeah, yeah, which --
-I'm in the apartment
right that way.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-Are we too loud or are we --
-Oh, you're totally fine.
-Okay, good. Yeah.
-Yeah.
You're on "Big Mouth"
on Netflix this Friday.
You're a voice of
one of the characters.
Congratulations on that.
And then,
another announcement came out
that I was very excited --
I didn't --
I should have congratulated you.
Sorry about that.
But congratulations.
You're going to be one of
the voices in the new
"Super Mario Bros." movie.
-Yeah.
-The movie.
-Movie.
-Yeah.
It's called a movie.
-It's called a movie.
Google it.
-Look it up.
-Look it up in the dictionary.
-Yeah.
-It's called a movie.
-It's a movie.
How long have they lasted?
Oh, I don't know. Decades.
-Look it up in a thesaurus.
-Yeah.
-Another name for it is film.
-Movies.
-It's called movies.
-Yeah.
-Go to one.
-Be in one.
-Yeah.
-Do you remember encyclopedias?
Do you remember,
like, how big they were
and how many you would have?
-Yeah, I had a whole collection.
-Yeah.
Like, that's what you went to.
Like, "Well, we'll look it up."
-Yeah, everyone would go,
"Oh, yeah, we'll look it up."
-Yeah.
-Then Microsoft Encarta.
-You know, stuff like that.
-Yeah.
-So, we'll talk about
stuff like that.
-Who will --
-When we get out on the air.
-Oh, we're gonna talk about
encyclopedias and --
-Yeah, stuff like that.
-Yeah.
-Microsoft Encarta.
You know,
maybe bring up Prodigy.
You'll go,
"Do you remember Prodigy?"
And I'll say, "Yeah, I do."
Then you'll say,
"Oh, do you remember, like,
they used to have, like --
You had to dial in --
the phone dial in.
It would go...
[ Imitates modem ]
That will get a laugh.
-But shouldn't it
do it to the audience?
Don't you feel like it should be
like, "Do you guys remember?"
It should be more like that.
Like, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
So maybe -- You come out.
I sit here.
No, no. You sit there.
-I sit here.
-Yeah.
-And then you're gonna
go like -- I go --
So, I'll say,
"Microsoft Encarta,"
and you go --
-Do you guys remember the sound?
That kind of thing.
[ Light cheering ]
Yeah. See? A little cheer.
-That's a bit.
And you do that.
And you go out there
and you do the Prodigy bit.
[ Both mumbling ]
-And then -- So,
then I'm sort of surprised.
I go, "Whoa, no --
And you've been there."
-Yes. Yeah.
-Oh. And Greece is beautiful.
Wonderful.
-Yeah, we'll talk about Greece.
-The Greece and the ocean.
-And then I'll go,
"Hey, Sandy, I can't believe."
And you go, "Not that one."
-"Not that one."
-Don't be silly.
And I go, "Yeah, sorry.
Back to the project.
-Yeah, back to the project.
-I had good time
filming in Greece.
-Yeah, filming in Greece.
-The director's a good friend.
-A good friend of mine, genius.
-Genius.
-You know,
wonderful and fantastic.
-We have lunch. Yeah, yeah.
-And then, funny story, I guess.
"And, so, they ordered falafel,
and this guy looks at me."
And, you know...
-Yeah, and he goes,
"We're not open,"
and now I feel awful.
I ordered a falafel,
-Yeah.
But you don't have to do
any of this stuff.
You know, it's all material.
I want you to come out
and be real.
-I like -- This is very much
the real me,
and I like talking about
those things.
-Wait. So, Fred talk to me
about "Big Mouth."
So, you're in the show?
And who do you play?
You're Nick Kroll's dad.
-I'm his dad.
And his name is Elliot.
-It's fun to do.
And it's based -- The voice --
This is for real.
I know we've been doing
a lot of bits.
You guys are
so patient and so nice.
But I did the voice to sound
like Henry Winkler.
-Really?
-You know, 'cause in interviews,
he's very -- he's very warm.
-Wow! That's an amazing
Henry Winkler impression.
That is exactly him.
-Oh, thanks.
-That is amazing.
-Thanks. Thank you.
-That actually sounds
exactly like --
-You know what I mean, right?
-Yeah.
-Because he's sincere
and he talks about --
You can hear a little bit
of New York in there,
a little bit.
-Yes, a little bit.
Oh, my gosh.
-And so --
-Dude, have you ever
done this for Henry Winkler?
-No. I didn't think about
doing it,
but only for the voice for this.
-He's going to freak out.
This is him.
-Wow. That's so nice of you.
-That's an amazing Henry.
I'm freaking out, yeah.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Fred in
the new season of "Big Mouth."
Take a look at this.
-Okay, I get it. I've heard you.
You don't love me anymore.
You want a divorce,
that's fine.
All I ask is
100% custody of you.
-I don't want a divorce, Elliot.
I just want to have
a real conversation
about our daughter having sex.
-Oh, you want a
real conversation, do you?
-Yes, I do.
-Well, here's what I think.
Leah is ready to have sex
when Leah says
she's ready to have sex,
because we made Leah
ready to have sex
when Leah's ready to have sex.
-I know, but you need to let me
have my feelings about it!
-I'm yelling, but I'm actually
very sorry about that.
-More with Fred Armisen when
we come back, everybody.